so it's not to attract a mate no no i
feel like for some people that's because
some people would generally they do want
to breathe but my my i didn't even get
my point like my point was to say that
women are everywhere and how guys say
like guys will go after a woman um and
so women are getting more attention in
that sense and it's like this eighty
percent of men that are not getting
anything
a lot of women don't want the attention
that they're getting that's that's the
only point i was bringing up what do you
mean i felt when you mean women get
unwanted attention yeah lots of times
yeah i mean you don't want
what happens when you don't get any
attention exactly you don't you don't
want it until you don't get it
because i've i've seen tick-tock videos
all over tick-tock of women saying oh my
god like i dressed up today little no
guys
they're not even hollering at me when
women die because i believe that women
attention is something that drives a lot
of women if women get no attention from
no men
they're not happy
honest so for me this is just purely me
when i dress up and i'm getting ready i
would rather a compliment from like a 13
year old little girl on the street
thinking my outfit's sick then a man
coming up to me trying to trust me i
thought no but it's not necessarily
chirpzin but acknowledging the fact that
you look good no but i get his point
like even if you don't like
fancy the guy even if it's like ill
you would rather
in your head you don't want that until
you don't have that but i'm i'm saying
like i just i wouldn't care at that
point just don't talk to me i feel like
maybe like originally like it was for
like men but then because it became so
inbuilt into society like girls getting
their hair done and stuff like it just
became something that you might have
seen like for yourself
but then
with like
men like we still see it like the same
thing like maybe you don't see it that
way but we do
i think it goes back to traditionally
like you're meant to leave the house
looking nice like i don't care how i
look all the time but um traditionally
like you're meant to leave the house as
your best self um because when you don't
know who you're going to see like
whether it's for work or for
um
or anything do you think you should be
allowed to to turn it off and on
whenever you feel like
so in the sense of what do you wear and
do when you want to attract a mate you
don't you don't you just say the same
thing also like if it if like you said
like maybe someone from work like do you
want someone from work to see you like
in b shorts
and a crop top
um well i'm saying like
in the sense of
how traditionally how people are meant
to leave the house is in that theory you
don't know who you're going to see i
personally i don't care like i walk
around with shorts all the time like
that's that's what i'm comfortable doing
that's what i like wearing i mean i
could walk around on the thongs and no
t-shirt but hang on with what i don't
know
you'll be around that with a thong yeah
and a vest like i mean i mean i could do
this
but look dave i remember those are dave
chappelle dave chappelle said men don't
buy nice cars because they nightlife
because they like nice cars they buy
nice cars because they know women like
nice cars they like nice cars and so
they know that that's going to be the
trap quote-unquote to get a woman if a
woman sees that a man's got money
yeah nine times out of ten she's gonna
go for that man now women now you're
saying
women understand that men are attracted
to attractive women but when you walk
out your house or when you do that it's
not to attract a mate yeah
and not only not all the time
because i walk around half the time
looking like a bum okay like i'm not
trying to attract but you were still
attracted to tension
yeah but check this out
i think this year at least eighty
percent of men before he comes to talk
sorry guys guys one more time go and say
what you're saying i was going to say
before before manchester united you were
saying something go on yeah i'll just
say like partially
speaking to the mic please partially it
would be because of that because of um
attracting me to be honest
like up to an accident like it might not
be the complete reason but up to the
next day yeah
you know looking good it just it just
makes life progress a little better
speech can i just say like does every
not obviously everyone but when people
leave the house what i don't get the
goal with
trying to find a mate when i leave the
house i'm not thinking of
trying because you have a lot of options
but it's not even that like people go
through different stages you have a lot
of options but there's times in life
where like you don't want to you don't
want to be with anyone like there's
times when i've been openly celibate and
i'm out made myself look nice i'm not
trying to find someone i'm just trying
to do me and feel good about myself like
that was my healing process like trying
to feel good about me and looking good
and finding how
i present myself it's nothing to do with
anyone else yeah it's nice when i get a
compliment but i don't expect that from
a man if it comes from here's my point
what you think is beautiful and sexy is
exactly what a man thinks is beautiful
and sexy yeah
the reason why you
you're even wearing it is because at a
stage in time someone thought when i'm
going to make this a man would love to
see a woman wear this it's my point like
in the sense of if you if you walked out
with a hijab one or you walked out with
a wedding ring on i guarantee you the
amount of men that come up to you would
decrease by 90 percent who yeah if you
just had a wedding i don't think i hear
what you're saying
or you had a hit jab on i almost got it
for now i think i look sexy now i'm in a
men's xl t-shirt yeah and baggy trousers
i think i look like i don't care if a
guy thinks i look sexy in this one i
look fly you look pretty cool i'm not
trying to i'm not trying to look i'm not
it's not for anyone no but understand
the difference you look you look pretty
if you had a short skirt on you'd look
sexy
do you understand the difference so you
don't look
i disagree at some points like obviously
certain clothing
makes people attracted to you in
different ways
but i i don't agree with the fact that
oh like oh every time a woman leaves her
house she's trying to attract someone no
no i don't think that i'm saying she
can't not expect that to happen when
she's walking out of her house wearing
something that attract that a man is
attracted to what are we meant to wear
like a sack
i feel like they're gonna look either
way or try and talk to us if you have a
wedding ring on then that should be
appropriate
yeah cause like it's not it's not hard
if you see yourself getting married a
lady with like a wedding ring on
you're not gonna like disrespect next
man by going up to his goal you'd be
supposed to try it
right you would be really sick you do
but it's not as like you would you'll
get rid of ninety percent of men yeah
yeah wait guys you have you never heard
like when people go to a bar like ladies
will come in with a wedding ring on
purely just to stop
most men from coming to them i mean like
i can't like i've done it if they're in
the bar they're in the
how did it work out for you when you did
it i mean i feel like it was about the
same
like as far as guys coming up to me but
it wasn't like an amazing amount of
numbers or it wasn't like
one person so it was about the same